esophageal cancer is a disease that
begins in your esophagus
your esophagus is a muscular tube that
food passes through from your mouth to
your stomach
the flat thin cells lining your
esophagus are called squamous cells
below the surface cells divide and
flatten to make new sway michelle's as
the old ones wear out
if you have a condition called gastro
esophageal reflux or GERD you frequently
have a backflow or reflux of acid from
your stomach into your esophagus
over time GERD may cause the squamous
cells lining your lower esophagus to be
replaced with gland cells that make
mucus called goblet cells
this change in the lining of your
esophagus is a condition called
Barrett's esophagus
one type of esophageal cancer called
adenocarcinoma may occur in the changed
lining of Barrett's esophagus
another type of esophageal cancer called
squamous cell carcinoma occurs in the
squamous cells in your esophagus
like all cancers both of these types
begin when damaged or abnormal genetic
material inside your cells causes them
to grow out of control
a tumor forms as the abnormal cells
begin to multiply
over time a lump may form in the wall of
your esophagus as the tumor grows
you may have no symptoms in the early
stages of esophageal cancer
later you may have trouble swallowing
when the tumor becomes large enough to
block part of your esophagus
having trouble with swallowing may cause
you to have difficulty eating as a
result you may lose weight in a short
period of time depending on the location
of the growing tumor you may also have
pain in your chest or neck
if you have esophageal cancer your
doctor may recommend one or more of the
following surgery
chemotherapy
and radiation therapy
surgery is the most common treatment for
esophageal cancer especially in the
early stages when the tumor is small
if you have a surgical procedure your
doctor will remove the section of your
esophagus that contains the tumor
as well as some normal tissue above and
below it
the surgery may include removing part of
your stomach
the remaining healthy esophagus and
stomach will be attached to each other
your surgeon may also remove nearby
lymph nodes to see if cancer cells have
spread to them
your doctor may recommend chemotherapy
as a main treatment for more advanced
tumors or to shrink your tumor before
surgery chemotherapy uses drugs to stop
cancer from spreading by either stopping
or slowing down the growth of cancer
cells
your doctor may recommend radiation
therapy such as external beam radiation
therapy in addition to chemotherapy
radiation therapy damages and kills the
esophageal cancer cells
some common ways to reduce your risk of
esophageal cancer include seeking
treatment if you have gastro esophageal
reflux or GERD
quitting smoking
and avoiding alcohol
you